Freunde ihr habt es euch gewünscht ich
habe es mir gewünscht ich bin hier beim
street food Festival in Düsseldorf
wirklich wir sind eine Minute hier es
gibt glaube ich ganz ganz viele leckeres
Essen und wir testen uns einfach
gemeinsam durch alles durch diese
Gerüchte die jetzt schon aufgehen ja vor
dem Eingang wo man gerade das Ticket
gekauft hat und es riecht so gut lasst
uns gemeinsam genießen und einfach einen
guten Tag haben
als allererstes eine kreolische
Spezialität venezian der stand ich
glaube der ist hier so ein kleiner
Geheimtipp also ich habe das Essen nur
gesehen und dachte mir direkt let's go
der ist weniger perfekt durchgesellt
aber das ist auch ganz geil dass sie uns
genießen wir sind hier übrigens heute
mit einer großen Truppe aufgezogen
selbst unter anderem auch dabei und wir
müssen direkt den ersten Stopp probieren
ich habe euch das Gefühl dass bei so
food Trucks noch mal so ein anderes
Level an Passion da ist so kleineren
Karten komm lass uns einfach
[Musik]
die Süße von den Bananen knallt einen
direkt komplett aus dem Leben
alles daran ist lecker ich finde
wirklich Mais und maisgebäck ist so
krass auch in der mexikanischen Küche
ist es einfach so lecker es ist ja
meistens der gleiche Grundteig so diese
Maismehl Mischung ne die einfach in so
verschiedensten Arten zubereitet wird
jetzt hier in der Repa oder in der
Empanada das fängt sowieso stark an
alter ich hatte wirklich am meisten Lust
hier drauf wie man sich ja alles anders
aus so lecker aber das so ein Ding ist
heute nach Hause und ich bin einfach nur
traurig dass das in Köln nicht gibt die
kann es so gut sein du siehst auch die
kochen so richtig so mit Herz geil ab
zum nächsten Stand der wirklich fällt so
schwer sich irgendwo für zu entscheiden
das ist so irre wir haben hier jetzt
Orchester waren Ferkel mit 15 Kräutern
Leute ihr seht das gleich solche miesen
Dinger auf Focaccia erstmal das
[Musik]
kann Italia borghetta
das ist street food für mich so dass sie
diesen Burger ist eigentlich im Prinzip
ein Burger also Focaccia dass sie dieses
Focaccia auf der Plancha belegen und die
Unterseite vom Brot noch mal so in
diesem gesamten Fett in dem gesamten
Geschmack einfach nochmal so ein
bisschen Crunch bekommt guckt euch das
an ist schwimmt so gefühlt in diesem
Papier ich habe keine Ahnung was mich
erwartet habe ich noch nie gegessen los
geht's oder
[Musik]
crispy herzhaften und schmeckt nicht
Focaccia sah für mich sehr unscheinbar
aus aber es hat so diese so ein bisschen
so porös wie so ein Focaccia oder so no
joke alles hier rein einfach krass
diese Zwiebelmarmelade Joghurtsoße
frischer Rucola ist einfach krass die
Mission ist einfach nur fünf Kilo
zunehmen so wäre das schafft hat
gewonnen bro
[Musik]
hallo
Adobo philippinische Küche wir haben
hier als probierarbeit einmal Bauchspeck
Doppel frittiert gebacken und
anscheinend absolut krank mit ein
bisschen Sesam drauf
boah Bruder ganz krank ja boah die Soßen
sind so intensiv das ist so wieder auf
geschmacksintensitätskala also wie stark
schmeckt es ist eine absolute zehn kommt
wenn immer hinter der Kamera ein rein oh
Alter oh mein Gott sehr sehr krank
Bauchspeck einfach prädestiniert dafür
so einfach auch so im Mund so zu platzen
ne man kann ich gar nicht vorstellen die
intensiv das schmeckt und jetzt hier
deren take auf das traditionelle chicken
Adobo wir haben Chicken Wings hör mal ja
ein bisschen Reis und zwei kleine
Kügelchen so wie er die Eiskugeln
[Musik]
die sind soft drin außen komplett frei
knusprig und das Ding ist langsam kriege
ich Jetlag weil ich durch so viele
verschiedene Länder schon gereist bin
mit meinem Daumen Alter wirklich langsam
so ein bisschen benommen davon wir haben
so viel leckeres Essen von überall auf
der Welt und es macht einfach so viel
Spaß was zu entdecken wir haben noch so
viel zu entdecken Alter sollen wir zum
nächsten Spot habe ich schon aufs Ende
des Videos da gehen wir nämlich noch mal
in die süße Masse rein in die
dessertwave und keine Sorge übrigens
hier ist das nicht alles alleine ich
teile das mit den anderen da gehen wir
jetzt wieder hin und danach geht's zum
nächsten Mal
[Musik]
ich sag euch ehrlich danach war es das
mit herzhaft für mich ich würde so gerne
noch mehr essen aber es geht einfach
nicht so richtig ich bin auch nur ein
Mensch so ich kann es waren an wie viel
Spots vier fünf dann ist auch irgendwann
gut Fried Chicken wenn der Typ Police
source let's go
okay
[Musik]
das schmeckt wirklich eins zu eins wie
chicken ja was soll ich sagen Alter die
Source sehr sehr geil schicken ist
tender die Waffe knusprig an sich weiß
ich nicht ob es einen krassen benef oder
was
aber sieht geil aus also würde sagen das
schaffe ich jetzt mal irgendwie zu essen
und dann geht's los mit den süßen Sachen
weil dafür hat man bekanntlicherweise am
zweiten Frage
Kokos endlich ist es soweit die Sweet
Spots sind eingeleitet wir haben hier
afrikanische Quarkbällchen Rene haben
sie gesagt ne heißen die eine oben ein
bisschen Schokosoße drauf Kokosraspeln
man merkt schon
crispy und rein da
kennt man den Geschmack man kennt ihn
nicht nicht eins zu eins weil so diese
Kokosnote ist anders ich habe auch im
Teig ist ein bisschen Kokos drin sind
super fluffig ich sag ehrlich ich bin
traurig dass jetzt beim Heim schon die
gesamte Soße Weg ist so da haben wir ein
bisschen gespart an der Soße ne aber
nicht desto trotz fluffy Frisbee geiler
Snack und auch am fairer Preis so von
allem was wir bisher auf dem Markt
hatten also schon alles ein bisschen
teurer als gutes Essen darf seinen Preis
kosten aber drei Stück 3,50 € einfach
sehr sehr fair und ich freue mich jetzt
auf die weiteren sweet spots
[Musik]
ganz genau so Eis am Stiel Wassereis
oder so eine Special Kreation leider ich
glaube ganz klassisch das mit Limette
Limette war leider ausverkauft ich hätte
so gerne eins mit Limette gegessen aber
Wassermelone Kiwi klingt auch nicht so
schlecht
okay sehr krank weißt du warum weil du
schmeckst es nur erwartest bei
Wassermelone irgendwie so was wirst und
es ist wirklich einfach Wassermelone
also es ist so einfach die Frucht
gefroren was soll uns ernst gerade
digital
aber auch vor allen Dingen einfach eine
geile Abkühlung an so einem geilen
sonnigen Tag alter das ist das was wir
brauchen oder ist eine sehr willkommene
Abkühlung und ich finde es faszinierend
weil es ist einfach du schmeckst die
Frucht
[Musik]
okay wir sind jetzt bei einem
strudelstand es ist quasi Strudeln ich
kann schon nicht mehr so gut denken wir
haben Apfels im Apfelbeeren Apfel dark
chocolate Apfel Vanilla white chocolate
und Afrika Karamell okay was ist denn
deine Empfehlung wäre oder Apfel
Karamell tatsächlich okay Apfelbeeren
Strudel einmal bitte
Angst vor Apfelstrudel weil in
Apfelstrudel sind immer Rosinen und ja
hast du Rosinen dann hast du vielleicht
berechtigterweise Angst aber da Rosinen
nicht jedermanns lieblingsbestandteil
sind sind hier vielleicht auch gar keine
drin erstmal den vanillesoßen Test
so eine ganz klassische Vanillesoße die
so die drängt sich nicht so im
Vordergrund ist einfach eine stabile
Vanillesoße guck mal guck mal guck mal
wir haben wirklich die Berrys da drin
wir haben hier eine Blaubeere Acker
Traube und jetzt Rennen
[Musik]
scharfes Messer und Topf ja geil das ist
ja letzter Zeit ein absoluter Trend
geworden alle möglichen fillings
Toppings und sonst was auf dem Weg
jeglicher Art zu machen aber hier hat es
einen Grund du hast diesen knusprigen
Sprudel das innen drin ein weiches
fluffiges Inneres und so eine nice
beerennote ich gebe ihm den benefit of
the doubt ich habe gerade so ein übelst
süßes Wasser gar nicht süß Textur mäßig
ist eigentlich nur zehn wär geil wenn er
noch so ein bisschen warm wäre aber wie
wie sonst funktioniert ich glaube danach
musst du schlafen gehen ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass es so schwer werden würde
mich zu entscheiden wofür ich so meinen
Hunger ausgebe checkst du also ich habe
aber glaube ich eine echt gute Wahl
getroffen alles was wir gegessen haben
war echt lecker und manche Sachen waren
krass krass ich träume glaube ich noch
von diesem Pass heute morgen oder heute
Mittag das war wirklich sehr sehr geil
auch so ein Tag muss ein Ende haben
deshalb vielen Dank fürs zuschauen wenn
ihr wollt dass sie sowas noch mal machen
sag bescheid ich habe eine ganz krasse
Idee schon bevor wir hier waren
entwickelt vielleicht hört ihr dazu mal
mehr wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder haut rein macht's gut
[Musik]